[Music]
Anna you had such a powerful scene early
in season 5 where you repeatedly yell
shut up shut up shut up and then of
course in the society we live in now
it's turned into a ringtone apparently
so
it's quite popular actually I think we
have it right now can we play that
[Applause]
imagine being in the doctor's office
when they say please turn off their cell
phones yeah that's not the Opera Brian
is well-known for trying to lighten the
mood bring silliness to the set and he's
not afraid to use any means necessary
that's that true that is true that is
true and it often involves either
wearing underwear or not wearing any
underwear at all really yes
so I think it started in the pilot right
oh yeah and if it was the you were
directing that episode and it was the
scene where you get into bed next to me
and say and I and you cuddle up next to
me and I say well does that you and you
you put some interesting some
interesting something in your tighty
whities to enhance the situation but I
know what that is what is it what you
put in there Walter jr.
[Laughter]
he's not off you're a junior I don't
know some sort of phallus of some sorts
it was a can of hairspray I believe
there's a can of hairspray Wow I'll take
anything as a phallus microphone no no
this is mine